>> Greg: DEMOCRATS, BEWARE OF
THE SOCCER MOMS.
NEW "WALL STREET JOURNAL" POLL
SAYS THE G.O.P. GETTING A MAJOR
BOOST FROM WHITE SUBURBAN WOMEN
AHEAD OF THE MIDTERMS.
MAKEUP 20% OF THE ELECTORATE.
THIS KEY GROUP FAVORS
REPUBLICANS BY 15 PERCENTAGE
POINTS.
THAT'S 27-POINT SWING FROM
AUGUST.
THE SHIFT NOT SURPRISING.
DEMOCRATS SEEM TO BE ASLEEP AT
BIDEN'S EVENTS.
>> ARGUE WITH WITH ME?
OKAY.
COME ON, PEOPLE.
LET'S WAKE UP.
WE'VE GOT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE HOUSE.
>> Greg: MY FAVORITE MARGE
SIMPSON'S SISTER.
ANYWAY.
DO KNOW WHAT I THINK?
I THINK MAYBE WOMEN ARE BEING
TIRED OF BEING CALLED RACIST
KARENS.
HAVING TO BE LIKE OKAY, I AM FOR
DRAG QUEEN STORY HOUR.
TIRED OF THIS WOKEISM.
>> Katie: I THINK THERE'S A
LOT THEY ARE TIRED OUT.
WHEN ROE V. WADE WAS OVERTURNED
AN ABORTION WAS SENT BACK TO THE
STATES DEMOCRATS THOUGHT THIS
WAS THEIR MOMENT TO KEEP FEMALE
VOTERS IN THEIR CAMP BUT PEOPLE
STARTED REALIZING WHEN THE
TEMPERATURE WAS LOWER THAT IT
WAS SIMPLY AVAILABLE TO THE
STATES TO MAKE THEIR OWN RULES
AND ABORTION DIDN'T CHANGE A LOT
OF THE PLACES WHERE THEY WANT
MORE UNRESTRICTED ABORTION SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS.
THE OTHER THING IS OF COURSE THE
SCHOOL ISSUE.
THE NIGHT BEFORE GLENN YOUNGKIN
WON THE GOVERNORSHIP IN
VIRGINIA, RANDI WEINGARTEN
CAMPAIGNED WITH
TERRY McAULIFFE.
SHE IS NOW IN MICHIGAN
CAMPAIGNING FOR GRETCHEN WHITMER
WHO SAID SHE DIDN'T ACTUALLY
CLOSE THE SCHOOLS FOR THAT LONG.
PARENTS ARE SAYING, ESPECIALLY
WOMEN, SEEING THAT THEIR KIDS
ARE BEHIND, THERE COMMUNITIES
ARE NOT AS SAFE AND I THINK THEY
ARE SICK OF DEMOCRATS FOCUSING
ON THEM AS A ONE ISSUE VOTER IN
TERMS OF ABORTION WHEN THERE'S
OTHER ISSUES LIKE INFLATION,
CRIME, EDUCATION.
OF >> Greg: THAT'S GOOD POINT.
JESSICA, YOU'RE A WHITE WOMAN,
OR SO YOU IDENTIFY ASKED.
IS THIS MORE ABOUT MARRIED WOMEN
VERSUS SINGLE WOMEN?
BECAUSE YOU HAVE KIDS, THAT
CHANGES YOUR FILTER AND SUDDENLY
IT'S ABOUT THE PRICE OF BABY
FOOD, NOT THE PRICE OF AN
ABORTION.
ABORTION TAKES A BACKSEAT TO
APPLESAUCE.
IS THAT A FAIR ASSESSMENT?
>> Jessica: MARRIED WOMEN DO
ALSO HAVE ABORTIONS.
THAT IS SOMETHING TO NOTE.
>> Greg: IT'S A VALIANT POINT,
JESSICA.
THEY CAN BE JUST AS MURDEROUS AS
SINGLE WOMEN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jessica: SURE.
I'M NOT GOING TO FALL DOWN THE
TRAP OF SAYING THAT WOMEN VOTE
HOW THEIR HUSBANDS VOTE BECAUSE
WE'VE SEEN OBVIOUSLY THAT THAT
IS DIVERGED.
>> Greg: ONLY THE SMART WOMEN,
JESSICA.
>> Jessica: TRYING TO GET ME
IN TROUBLE.
SO THESE WERE NEVER OUR VOTERS.
THEY SWING IN AND OUT DEPENDING
ON THE ELECTION, AND 2020 HAD A
REALLY BIG NAME ON THE BALLOT.
DONALD TRUMP'S NAME ON THE
BALLOT AND THAT'S HOW WE WERE
ABLE TO PICK OFF SO MANY WHITE
SUBURBAN VOTERS WHO TYPICALLY
VOTE REPUBLICAN.
THE TIMING OF THE DECISION, IT
FELT LIKE WHEN THE MOMENTUM WAS
GOING OUR WAY AND YOU HAVE THE
KANSAS REFERENDUM ET CETERA,
THIS WAS GOING TO HOLD.
THEN CONDITIONS IN THE ECONOMY
DIDN'T IMPROVE VERY MUCH AND
CRIME BECAME A SUPERSEDING ISSUE
TO WHERE ABORTION IS SO I DON'T
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT ISN'T
IMPORTANT TO THEM BUT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO RANK YOUR
CHOICES, YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
PICK A LANE AND WHITE SUBURBAN
WOMEN, I DIDN'T EXPECT A
26-POINT SWING BUT THEY ARE
PICKING A LANE AND IT'S NOT
VOTING ON A SOCIAL ISSUE.
VOTING ON A BREAD AND BUTTER
ISSUE LIKE PUBLIC SAFETY.
>> Greg: DANA, SEEMS LIKE
THOSE WHITE SUBURBAN WOMEN LIKE
TO SWING.
>> Dana: HAVE YOU HEARD ABOUT
THAT?
THERE'S A SHOW ON NETFLIX.
>> Greg: IS NOT MAINLY ABOUT
THE PRICE OF THINGS, INFLATION.
>> Dana: ALSO THINK THAT FOR
WOMEN WHO OFTEN CONTROL THE
SPENDING OF THE HOUSEHOLD, GOING
BACK TO SCHOOL IS VERY
EXPENSIVE.
YOU'VE GOT THE SPORTS FEES AND
ALL THE THINGS THAT YOU GOT TO
PAY FOR.
THAT WAS KIND OF SHOCKING FOR
THEM AND THEN YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE
LUNCHES AND EVERYTHING.
WOW, SO MUCH MORE EXTENSIVE.
I FEEL LIKE THE DEMOCRATS
WOULDN'T RECOGNIZE A KITCHEN
TABLE IF IT HIT THEM IN THE
FACE.
THINK ABOUT THE YEAR BEFORE, THE
MIDTERMS, REPUBLICANS WERE ABLE
TO PICK UP RACES AND A LOT OF
THOSE PLACES.
THIS HAS BEEN COMING.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING NEW.
I PICKED UP SOMETHING YOU MIGHT
LIKE TODAY.
TALKING ABOUT OREGON.
LOOKS LIKE A FEW OF THE
CONGRESSIONAL RACES MIGHT FLIP
TO REPUBLICAN BUT ALSO THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE AND THERE WAS A
WOMAN, A MOTHER WHO WAS
INTERVIEWED AND SHE SAID HER BIG
ISSUE IS THE FOLLOWING.
WHAT'S YOUR FAVORITE WORD THAT
YOU USE --
>> Greg: PROBLEMATIC.
>> Dana: IT'S BROWN.
YOUR FAVORITE EMOJI.
>> Greg: POO.
>> Dana: IT SHE SAID SHE DOES
NOT WANT TO TAKE HER KIDS TO THE
INDEPENDENT BOOK STORE A GUY
DEFECATING ON THE SIDEWALK IN
FRONT OF HER CHILDREN.
SHE HAS HAD IT.
SHE'S HAD ENOUGH.
>> Katie: SHE SHOULD
CALM DOWN.
>> Jessica: I AM THE CALMEST
I'VE BEEN IN WEEKS.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE A WHITE
WOMAN.
>> Jessica: AND OVEREDUCATED.
>> Greg: I HOPE YOU COME UP
WITH AN ANALOGY THAT MAKES ALL
OF US UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> Jesse: NO ONE KNOWS WHITE
SUBURBAN WOMEN BETTER THAN I DO.
JEEP GRAND CHEROKEE'S, ITALIAN
FOOD, STARBUCKS, J.CREW.
DAVE MATTHEWS BAND, LULULEMON.
I'VE GOT IT ALL DOWN.
YOU'RE RIGHT, THEY DO SWING.
THEY ARE UP FOR GRABS AND THEY
HUNDRED FOR TRUMP AT FIRST IN
2016 BECAUSE HE WAS EXCITING.
AND THEN ALL HELL BROKE LOOSE
BECAUSE HE WAS TOO
CONTROVERSIAL.
THEY DON'T LIKE TOO MUCH
CONTROVERSY.
AND THEN THE QUARANTINES, THE
WHOLE FAMILY STAYED INSIDE THE
HOUSE AT THE SAME TIME.
THAT WAS WAY TOO MUCH.
THEY JUST WANTED TO GO BACK TO
NORMAL BIDEN.
HE SAID HE WOULD GET US BACK TO
NORMAL.
THEN THEY WENT RADICAL LEFT AND
IT WAS LIKE WHIPLASH FOR THE
SUBURBAN WHITE WOMEN BECAUSE ALL
OF A SUDDEN YOU GET HIGH PRICES
AND CRIME.
WHAT DO SUBURBAN WHITE MEN WANT
TO TALK ABOUT?
THE PRICE OF EVERYTHING.
GAS, HOME RENOVATIONS, AND THEN
THE SUBURBAN WHITE WOMEN, THEY
TALK ABOUT SAFETY, SCHOOLS, AND
SHOPPING, THE PRICE OF
EVERYTHING.
THEY GET INVOLVED AND EVERYONE
HE STARTS TALKING AND IT'S JUST
NOT COOL ANYMORE TO BE BIDEN
VOTER IN THE SUBURBS.
IT'S A LET'S GO, BRANDON
SITUATION.
IT'S NOT COOL.
THE ONLY PEOPLE IN THE SUBURBS
THAT SUPPORT JOE BIDEN AT THIS
POINT OUR WEIRDOS AND PEOPLE
WITH GRADUATE DEGREES.
SO IF YOU CAN JUST GET THINGS
BACK TO NORMAL AND BE NO DRAMA,
THE WHITE SUBURBAN WOMEN WILL
LOVE YOU.
>> Jessica: THAT REALLY
EXPLAINED IT.
>> Greg: IT CERTAINLY DID.
I'M LETTING IT WASH OVER ME.
>> Jesse: I AM LETTING YOU
THINK.
>> Jessica: WHY DO YOU CALL
THEM GUYS?
>> Greg: